a generation after the Berlin Wall came
down the city is still divided by this
Alexander Platz it's a transportation
hub it's the core of old East Berlin and
now it's the scene of conflict between
developers and preservationist that
can't be swept underground the question
for investors which buildings will make
way for billion-dollar redevelopments in
which will be tied up in red tape
statistics can be dizzying but the house
of statistics can't wriggle free of its
fate it's scheduled to be demolished
this is the house of electro technology
it's long like a skyscraper falling
outside for an entire city block its
owners are worried that a landmark
designation will complicate or slow
development as you can see it architects
like Daniel Festa tog whose office
overlooks the square see the need for a
revamp you look at the high-rise here
and seeing that plinth for the
department store and there it looks
pretty shabby that Square is not really
enjoyable and because there's so much
going on well there's clearly money to
be made in development there's history
to be lost the park in an East German
time nearly every room was bugged and
prostitutes would spy on their clients
historically it's interesting
architecturally well just 37 stories of
glass developers have another nemesis
the earth a Frank Gehry project to build
germany's tallest apartment tower is
teetering the ground laced with subway
lines may not support its weight it
would have stellar views just like those
from the house of travel even inside
there are a few flaws not much Headroom
and not much room for a city to grow
Hans Nichols Bloomberg Berlin